a lot of people cannot see we can be the
tip player this lead facial well that
Robin Lopez that time came out on
rollerskates we started taking a lot of
threes and making Lopez on it tries to
set him up with a dribble
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
knows he will leave the Bucks again this
season he has four points in the early
going beyond ascribe
pitch the three in his first game
preseason game in his third stint with
the Buster on his back
don't turn it into a jumping contest
with a younger more athletic window
party this trip will be one of those
marches into football
[Applause]
we said when he could shoot from a
thirties make a bad shot he is
unstoppable fair enough open three
Hamilton wine great ball movement play
from the land and triplex who had to
wait for some help
[Music]
[Applause]
aniss has 14 points he got by holiday
for the flush model depending on his
back now this grabs the rebound holds
off pain gets the ball back and wins it
in defenders meeting zach lavine in the
paint and results in a turnover so far
tonight there's a play by Yannick Watson
just take off right through Jabari and
Robin Lopez the beautiful finish since
the pair's
beautiful finishes the teams that keeps
the juices flowing keeps you compete
first Don takes it after the Miss take a
look this path from Yanis no-look
wraparound number right around Robin
Lopez and that's beautiful basketball
he's seven remaining in the third
quarter
fake down tonight and finds her farm for
the first basketball game played matter
bucks in their new home
drive
No